alright so I I am Silas ready mentioned
I'm on the team that does cured vote we
work here at the times and I was as I
was saying the thing I'm going to be
talking about today is a tool that we've
been developing to do test reporting for
our functional automation sweets so our
systems internally what we have is a
framework that ready alluded to that
handles interfacing to our systems under
test managing our business data man dart
business data model and managing our
data sets that we use for our data
driven testing these nose for test
discovery and for handling management of
test fixtures and we have a plug-in that
tugs into our framework to control
data-driven trusting through our
interface and it does some rudimentary
reporting is anybody that's used knows
it's definitely ready mentary right we
have Hudson to basically manage a level
above knows to schedule our tests and
manage our test Suites and again um
deriving from X unit reporting from
knows we have some test results some
level of test reporting in Hudson but
again Hudson is not the best thing of a
test report later but we're like Python
because we actually like to have the
flexibility to write our tests in proper
programming language instead of using
you know one of those graphical test
writing tools
that not be great so as I was saying
some of our problems will run into our
jobs don't necessarily map 12 12 a test
suite because we have parameterize jobs
right so say we run our e-commerce test
suite right and we have a parameter to
specify whether it's you know the BBT
run or like a full regression sweet but
I don't know how many of you are
familiar with what noses reporting looks
like it gives you a little graph of your
history but obviously if you're running
different sets of tests from the same
job that really doesn't mean anything to
you anymore right so that's one problem
um the dumped excellent tests um there
they can be kind of confusing to begin
to they're just flat text they don't
capture all the data we want like for
instance where we ran the test they're
not particularly searchable and they're
poorly archived since it just derives
from the history of Hudson and Hudson
calls itself sometimes we really wish it
didn't and then lastly the results are
not responsive so if you have a large
functional automation sweet it can take
you know multiple hours to run right and
given that you you still want to be able
to see I mean your tests aren't going to
be an eight hour long test right you're
going to want to see you know a couple
of minutes into it five tests of run
this is what's happened this is all your
log results but if you're relying on
Hudson to give you your reporting you're
not going to see pretty much anything
about what's happened until the end of
the test run so seven hours later hey
look you got all this stuff which was
not particularly useful if you were
trying to be you know maybe agile
so the tool season pocket change so
here's a little soup of things that have
logos and then something that doesn't
have a logo obviously I'm not a graphic
designer so that's nice so sneeze I'm
pocket change it's a structured as they
plug into nose and basically there's a
tugboat plug-in so sneeze is the most
plugin component that itself is
pluggable it basically manages the
logging of tests state what's currently
running your test result and then allows
plugins to do to add other things that
were we're keeping track of all the
tests are running then pocket change is
the front end that displays all this
thing and if you want to ask me why you
think this is a new that way I can get
into it later ready when they hated the
name of the last project that I came up
with so I spent some time something
about these ones so uh oh geez you can
mostly make out this image um so as I
was saying the sort of overall the
overarching architecture of the system
you have a tests written in our
framework the f knows yes knees and many
of pocket which is the component that
actually pushes log messages associated
to an executing test into a reporting
database and it just plays a little
logging module so obviously that's
there's some hacking that I had to do so
that's a place for improvement there but
in any case push this off to the
reporting database and then pocket
change which is the web GUI sits there
in front to let you look at everything
and it's nice and pretty so here's some
example code hopefully most so you guys
can made it this is just some setup
stuff so all this is is a test obviously
completely synthetic that
a science and variables does the math
with them and doesn't validation that
print some stuff are that logged some
stuff through logging module on top of
the wheel during the validation and then
this is just a test that logged it loops
six hundred times and logs message each
time and then sleeps 4 10 2 the second
so this is how we run it just adds a few
more available parameters to knows so in
those tests um I guess you should
probably mention it has a concept of
test cycle so a test cycle is just a
collection of test results it's so the
idea is you can print it say you have
you're doing like an agile thing and
have like to make sprint and say you
have a daily build process that runs
suite of function elimination tests so
you look well what the cut I I play is
when we build this out a little more I
mean it practically supports it into the
hood but there's nothing to build on top
of it yet but you can have basically
like parent and child test test cycles
so you could have a test cycle for like
a sprint or a build and child test
cycles for each day or if you want to do
something else like so a developer is
actually working on a ticket they can
have like a test cycle to track their
work through through a number of bugs
that have been filed and and show like
basically in real time hey look this
test failed here's this collection of
test results and I did some work and
that Iran is just again and out passes
so that's nice and I have a library that
people from Bob enjoy but unfortunately
it wasn't working friendly with the
network so instead I will just show
so this is the application so that you
got is a list of all the test cycles
that have been run and it's filterable
it right now this just filters on simple
text substring search on either the name
of the description and then you can get
it so this is all the tests the all the
test cases that have been written a
little bit run as part of the cycle so
as you can see here umm this is the doc
string so you actually get the purified
version and this is the test ID that's
sort of a loose internal there's some
features that we have that allowed you
to do to do reruns from data directly
from those because there's also a REST
API on this I'm sorry directly from this
noise plug-in component because there's
actually a REST API on this to that
gives you some more information and we
want to build this out into the future
to actually have execute capability
directly from the GUI obviously right
now it's just it's one way but we want
to make it to way so and then this is
filterable so you can look at all tests
that have any fat any family uh only
passes or only failures and this is
dynamic so if you have multiple you know
however many result states you have you
have filters for and then if we go in
here so this is all the information that
we logged from this test and as you can
see you get the the lagger this is just
the log in you that it was but it was
logged too so again i'm going to add I
didn't have to him today at it but
another filter another set of filters
say can you know filter by log level you
can filter by of the logo it came from
so only the idea here is you get you
would be able to build your tests in
such a way that they essentially proved
out exactly the steps that they went
through to get to where they got
um which is very nice if you're trying
to go in and reproduce an issue instead
of having to run the test with a
breakpoint and all that kind nonsense
and then let me just run there we go
I
not that one yes so here's an example of
multiple results into the same test
within a test cycle and then I just
wanted to show what it looks like as
it's wrong so I'll just click off I
think if I don't if I can stop fighting
with your cursor for a second here uh-uh
and actually get to show up over here it
actually will show you the if it passes
quick scan shows pending instead of pass
or fail and it actually logs it has a
number of settings for how frequently
you want to spit out information so you
can set like a number of log messages
you know you know every 10 seconds or
every 150 messages so you can kind of
control that too so that's pretty much
next on this and if we go back over to
my presentation so we are actually this
is open source type we'll just got it up
on the public it up today oh so you guys
can go if you have interest in looking
there and you can look through all our
repos 44 Snow's which is the core plugin
and then packet and there's actually
another component if we go back to the
this guy suddenly you might have noticed
that guy um there's actually a problem
for sneeze that integrates with JIRA so
you can so it will a test cycle will
have an issue that's associated to it
and you can like link that directly to
your you know your other workflow tasks
in JIRA if you happen to use JIRA we do
so that's why we have that but well
that's pretty much excellent
project and if you guys are interested
more than yeah we're definitely
interested in any ideas or bugs that you
might find and if you're interested in
contributing we're definitely looking
for pull requests and any other ideas
you might have okay I guess one of the
questions so awesome question no it's
he's asking what database on the
database referred to um it's sqlalchemy
so any driver that you can use with us
to alchemy I'm should work i mean it's
using SQL from the models so yeah that's
that's the that's the whole idea of the
tool so it's it's it's it's it's
targeted at managing functional
automation results in sort of in the
enterprise environment I mean well it's
a frost gap yeah any other questions
so nose is just an interesting framework
all it does is test discovery and like
fixture management kind of stuff though
the whole reason that this kind of
exists is because we like writing our
tests in a actual programming language
instead of being restricted there's lots
of tools out there that have these sort
of reporting interfaces but you're
forced to use like they're sort of
custom programming language or some like
graphical record and playback kind of
thing and those honestly kind of a
terrible for doing anything beyond the
demo that they show you on their website
so the idea was to add the nice features
of those tools onto a flexible testing
framework I mean it's just a Python
right so anything you can do in Python
you can you can use to run a test and
you can loosen a test that will report
into the system well
so so again that's that's to the side of
what this does right this isn't managing
the actual data or flow of the test this
is sitting on top of the running tests
and reporting what's happening from the
tests so it's it's not it's not really
the same domain any other questions okay